-Oh, whoa.
Thank you so much.
I moved here a couple of years
ago from Ireland,
and I love your Irish
restaurants over here.
They're so authentic,
you know?
[ Light laughter ]
I'm a big fan of
the quesadillas.
[ Laughter ]
Really just remind me
of home, you know?
I was in one of these
restaurants not so long ago.
I saw this on the menu --
"Irish Nachos."
[ Light laughter ]
Fantastic.
While I'm at it,
why don't I try
some of that famous
Canadian Sushi.
Here's the thing --
I like Irish food.
I like Mexican food.
Just advertise the place so
I know what to expect, you know?
Like, "Do you like stew
and fajitas?
Well, come on down to
Tac O'Flannigan's."
[ Laughter ]
"Free tequila shot
with your Shepherd's Pie."
[ Laughter ]
I used to work at a bar
in Manhattan.
And one time, I was serving
this guy, and he said to me,
"Uh, what's the least amount
of wings I can get?"
Uh...none.
[ Laughter ]
"You want me to ring that up
for you, or...?"
[ Laughter ]
I do comedy full-time, now.
I travel around a lot,
and I've noticed some people
over here feel very comfortable
complaining to me
about immigration
like I'm not also
an immigrant.
Can you imagine
how crazy I'd sound
if I agreed with them?
If I was just like,
"You know what? You're right.
I'm tired of these people
coming over here...
like I did."
[ Laughter ]
"They're trying
to take the jobs...
that I'm also
trying to take."
[ Laughter ]
"They never pay taxes....
I'm assuming,
'cause neither do I."
[ Laughter ]
"And the worst part about it,
they're coming from countries
with a history of
terrorist organizations...
[ Light laughter ]
...just like the IRA."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, thank you.
I've been traveling around
a lot, as I said.
And I love your airlines
over here,
'cause they're
all horrific.
[ Laughter ]
It's like they had a meeting
one day where they were like,
"You know,
if we're all terrible,
they have to fly
with one of us."
[ Laughter ]
And in that meeting,
they were like,
"Hey, United, you've been doing
awful well lately.
Maybe take it back
a notch."
United was like
"On it,"
and just started
tazing passengers
right, left, and center.
[ Applause ]
Oh, thank you.
Then, they moved on
to the next airline, like,
"Hey, guys,
we warned you."
And they were like
"Roger that,"
and just started drop-kicking
puppies off flights.
[ Light laughter ]
And then, they were like,
"Hey, Spirit...
keep up the good work."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause they are the mafia
of the sky.
[ Laughter ]
Last time I flew
with Spirit,
I showed up to the airport on
a Monday, and they were like,
"Eh, how about Thursday."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause they're the ones
who invented
this low-fares over here,
where they were like,
"How would you like
to save $40
for the low, low cost
of you dignity?"
'Cause they have all these
crazy stipulations.
They're like, "You don't get
a carry-on, no snacks.
Upon boarding the flight,
the pilot gets to
punch you in the nuts....
[ Light laughter ]
...and call you father
a coward."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, and in the event
that we need to pull
the evacuation slide,
a first-class passenger
gets to sit on your back
as they ride you to safety
like a toboggan."
[ Light laughter ]
And every time,
I'm just like,
"Well, if it'll
save me $40."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Although, clearly,
I'm exaggerating, there, guys,
you know, because Spirit
doesn't have first class.
[ Laughter ]
First class on Spirit
is just the seats
where the oxygen masks
actually come down.
[ Light laughter ]
But right before they do,
a credit-card machine
just descends from above,
like, "How much do you
want your air?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, that is the end
of my time.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
♪♪♪♪
-Sean Finnerty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-For more, go to
seanfinnertycomedy.com.